in this video we are going to talk about
proportional relationships and these are
relationships between two variables
where the ratio between the variables is
equivalent now if that sounds complex or
a little bit fancy it'll hopefully seem
a little bit more straightforward once
we look at some examples so let's say
i'm looking at a recipe for some type of
baked goods maybe it's some type of
pancakes i've been making a lot of those
lately
and we know that for a certain number of
eggs how many cups of milk we need so we
have number
of eggs
and then we're also going to have cups
of
milk
and in this recipe
we know
that if we're going to use one egg then
we would use two cups of milk and if we
use three eggs then we're going to use
six cups of milk and if we use let's say
12 eggs then we're going to use 24 cups
of milk so is this a proportional
relationship where the two variables are
the cups of milk and the number of eggs
well to test that we just have to think
about the ratio between these two
variables and you could say the ratio of
number of eggs to cups of milk or the
ratio of the cups of milk to the number
of eggs but to just to ensure that they
are always equivalent in these scenarios
so let me make another column here and
i'm going to think about the ratio of
the eggs
to the cups
of
milk
well in this first scenario one egg for
two cups of milk the second scenario is
three to six this third scenario is 12
to 24
are these equivalent ratios
well to go from 1 to 3 you multiply by 3
and we also to go from 2 to 6 you
multiplied by 3. so you multiplied both
the variables by 3. similarly if you
multiply the number of eggs by 4 then
you multiply the number of cups of milk
by 4 as well so these indeed are all
equivalent ratios 1 to 2 3 to 6 12 to
24. in every scenario you have twice as
much cups of milk as you have number of
eggs so this would be proportional so
check
now what would be an example of a
non-proportional relationship let's stay
in this baked goods frame of mind let's
say you're going to to a cake store and
you're curious about how much it would
cost to buy cake for different numbers
of people so let's say numbers
of servings
number of servings in one column and
then the cost of the cake
and let me set up two columns right over
here
and so let's say if you have 10 servings
the cake costs 20
if you have 20 servings the cake costs
30 dollars and if you have 40 servings
the cake costs 40 dollars pause this
video and see if you can figure out
whether this is a proportional
relationship if it is why if it isn't
why not all right well let's just think
about the ratios again so and here our
two variables are the number of servings
and the cost of cake so if we look at
the ratio of the servings
servings
to cost
so in this first situation it is 10
to 20 and then it is 20 to
30 and then it is 40
to 40.
and so to see if these are equivalent
ratios when we go from 10 to 20 on the
number of servings we're multiplying by
two
but when we go from 20 to 30 on the cost
of the cake we aren't multiplying by two
we're multiplying by 1.5 or one and a
half and similarly when we go from 20 to
40 we are multiplying by two again but
to go from 30 to 40 we aren't
multiplying by two we're multiplying by
one and one-third by one and one-third
when we multiply our servings by a given
amount we're not multiplying our cost of
cake by the same amount this tells us
that this is not
proportional
one way to think about proportional
relationships we already said that the
ratio between the variables will be
equivalent another way to think about it
is one variable will always be some
constant times the first variable so in
our first example right over here we
said the cups of milk is always two
times the number of eggs we can write
that down so cups
of milk
is always going to be equal to two times
the number
of eggs
and this number right over here we call
that the constant of proportionality and
you wouldn't be able to set up an
equation like this in this scenario it
would have to be more complicated and so
a proportional relationship the ratios
are equivalent between the two variables
and you can set it up with an equation
like this where you have a constant
of
of proportionality
proportionality